[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Sievers hallo
und guten Abend ihnen allen es ist noch
vieles mysteriös 70 Meter tief unten auf
dem Grund der Ostsee aber es mehren sich
die Indizien dass es eine gezielter
Sabotageakt war der die Pipelines
nordstream 1 und 2 möglicherweise für
immer zerstört hat so werden deutsche
Sicherheitsbehörden heute zitiert das
wäre eine neue extreme Stufe im
energiekrieg der Europa in diesem Herbst
und Winter herausfordert was heißt das
für die sogenannte kritische
Infrastruktur insgesamt an der unser
Alltag hängt und vielfach unser Leben
was heißt das für andere essentielle
Pipelines für flüssiggasterminals und
Stromtrassen nicht nur Norwegen will
seine Sicherheitsmaßnahmen jetzt
verstärken kündigt eine hohe
Militärpräsenz an aber klar ist auch
kompletten Schutz aller Anlagen kann es
gar nicht geben Florian neuhahn über
Europa auf Spurensuche zwischen
vorbereitet sein und alarmmodus
vielleicht sollte man damit beginnen was
das hier alles nicht ist kein Erdbeben
kein Unfall aber auch kein direkter
Angriff auf ein Land der NATO oder EU
sagt an Linde Außenministerin des
EU-Landes Schweden
ich möchte darauf hinweisen dass es sich
nicht um einen Angriff auf Schweden
handelt weil es nicht in unserem
Hoheitsgebiet liegt
die Klarstellung ist wichtig ein Angriff
nämlich das wäre die ultimative
Eskalation der Bündnisfall für die EU
oder im Fall Dänemarks die Nato und so
spricht etwa der Nato-Generalsekretär
heute vorerst von einem Akt der Sabotage
einer der Fragen aufwirft
die naheliegende erste wer steckt
dahinter ein Anschlag auf eine
Gasleitung auf dem Meeresboden das
können nicht viele sagt zum Beispiel der
ehemalige Chef des
Bundesnachrichtendienstes man muss
entweder mit Marine Tauchern arbeiten
oder Drohnen oder vielleicht sogar mit
Unterseebooten das ist alles nicht
trivial ich vermute sehr stark dass wir
hier mit einem staatlich gesponserten
Terrorismus zu tun haben staatlich
gesponsert aus Russland es ist was die
meisten im Westen vermuten unbeeindruckt
vom Dementi aus Moskau
es ist ziemlich vorhersehbar und
vorhersehbar dumm und absurd solche
Annahmen zu treffen
es wäre nicht die erste Lüge aus dem
Kreml und so stellt man sich in Brüssel
schon die nächste Frage
wie reagiert der Westen schon gestern
Abend kündigte eu-kommissionspräsidentin
vollmundig die stärkstmögliche Antwort
an heute Auftritt vor der Presse Ursula
von der Leyen spricht zwar über neue
Sanktionen gegen Russland aber als
Reaktion auf die letzte Eskalation nicht
die womöglich neue
akzeptieren weder scheinreferenten noch
irgendeine Art von Annexion in der
Ukraine und wir sind entschlossen den
Kreml den Preis für diese weitere
Eskalation zahlen zu lassen
zu den Pipelines kein Wort offenbar will
man abwarten die Untersuchung der lex
werde sicher noch zwei Wochen dauern
heißt es aus Dänemark und trotzdem ist
heute schon Zeit für die dritte Frage
was heißt das für die Zukunft
der mutmaßliche Anschlag liegt offen wie
verwundbar Europa ist längst nicht nur
beim Gas
das nächste Thema nach der
Energieinfrastruktur wird sicher die
Kommunikationsinfrastruktur sein denn
auch da liegen unter Wasser sehr viele
Kabel und man kann das als eine kleine
versteckte Drohung möglicherweise
empfinden wenn man denn der Ansicht ist
dass diese Anschläge aus Moskau
gesteuert sind europa muss seine
Infrastruktur besser schützen das hat
auch die EU erkannt und verpflichtet im
Juni die Mitgliedstaaten künftig
nationale Strategien dazu vorzulegen
wenigstens ein Anfang
zuständig für die innere Sicherheit in
der Europäischen Union ist die
innenkommissarin
ülva Johannsson und sie ist jetzt bei
uns aus Brüssel vor Johann von guten
Abend
guten Abend
sie sind Schweden vor ihrer Küste in
ihren wirtschaftsgewässern ist das ja
passiert ist das jetzt aus ihrer Sicht
geradezu ein Anschlag auf die EU
es sei schön
ich sollte das so sagen das muss
natürlich untersucht werden aber ich
nehme diesen Anschlag natürlich sehr
ernst und es zeigt natürlich auch
dekapazitäten so einen Anschlag zu
verüben hinsichtlich der kritischen
Infrastruktur also wir nehmen das sehr
ernst sie nehmen das sehr ernst aber
nachdem was sie als innenkommissarin
wissen wer könnte denn dann eine
Interesse daran haben diese Pipelines
jetzt zu sabotieren
intelligenter Anschlag der nicht sein
kann von einer normalen Gruppe von
Menschen also ein großes Risiko das doch
ein Starter hintersteht und ich glaube
dass das wirklich auch ein Warnruf ist
für uns dass wir wirklich sehr viel mehr
tun müssen um uns selbst zu schützen
gegen solche Anschlägen es ist eine
Eskalation die ich sehe eine Bedrohung
was wir jetzt tatsächlich tun müssen in
der EU sie sagten es ist steckt wohl ein
Staat dahinter haben sie da ein Verdacht
untersucht werden
sorgfältig untersucht werden dafür ist
es zu früh aber wir haben natürlich
einen Verdacht aber es ist so früh das
abschließend zu beurteilen jetzt ist es
ja so dass aktuell bereits alle
möglichen verschwörungsgeschichten
tatsächlich kursieren werden wir denn
irgendwann mal beweist sicher
herausbekommen können wer dahinter
steckt
ja
ich glaube es wird hier Untersuchungen
geben und es wird auch möglich sein zu
sehen wer da verantwortlich ist
was erwarte ich
wie sollen wir das sicherstellen können
was glauben Sie was sind da die Mittel
die Europa aktuell hat denn verhindern
konnten das ja offensichtlich nicht
das ist wirklich der Moment wo wir mehr
tun müssen und ich glaube eine der
Konsequenzen nach diesem Anschlag ist
sicherlich dass wir von seiten der
Kommission ein Belastungstest
vorschlagen werden in Bezug auf die
Einheiten der kritischen Infrastruktur
in den Mitgliedstaaten und wir hatten ja
bereits eine neue Regulierung
vorgeschlagen
gerade zum Schutz der kritischen
Infrastruktur in der europäischen
Europäischen Union und das wurde ja auch
angenommen und wir erwarten hier sehr
bald auch eine bessere Regulierung die
wir dann haben werden in der ganzen EU
das wurde angenommen da stehen aber eine
Reihe von Vorschlägen dann Hinweisen an
die Mitgliedsstaaten drin und es hat
anderthalb Jahre gedauert im typisch
europäischen Prozess bis tatsächlich
dieses Alarmsignal aus der Kommission
dann auch angenommen wurde das muss
jetzt in den Mitgliedsstaaten auch noch
tatsächlich umgesetzt werden sprich
besonders eilig schalten es ja die
Länder Europas damit nicht zu haben
fühlen Sie sich als innenkommissarin bei
diesem doch sehr drängenden und
wichtigen Thema manchmal auch ziemlich
machtlos
und wir werden uns jetzt an alle
Mitgliedstaaten wenden
wirklich einen Belastungstest
durchführen in Bezug auf die kritische
Infrastruktur wir werden auch auf dem
Mittelstaaten zugehen und uns dafür
einsetzen dass hier das umgesetzt wird
und eben auch hier die Maßnahmen zu
verstärken und gleichzeitig natürlich
auch die Entschlossenheit dass wir
reparieren müssen wenn etwas zerstört
wurde das ist sicherlich eine Reihe
unterschiedliche Schritte die
erforderlich ist aber wir haben uns
darüber ja bereits vor dem Krieg darüber
Gedanken gemacht was müssen wir schützen
aus dem Grund hatten wir ja auch die
neue Regulierung die bereits angenommen
wurde und jetzt müssen wir wirklich auch
rausgehen in die Mitgliedstaaten und
diese Belastung Test in Bezug auf die
kritische Infrastruktur durchführen denn
wir müssen uns immer wieder bewusst sein
dass neue Anschläge morgen oder
irgendwann sonst werden können vor
Jahren sondern das verstehe ich jetzt
noch nicht so ganz sie sprechen immer
von Belastungstests brauchen wir denn
jetzt noch einen Test brauchen wir nicht
ganz konkrete und ja tatsächlich
angehensweisen dass etwas sich ändert
und etwas passiert
jetzt ja das brauchen wir ja das
brauchen wir und das steht ja auch in
dieser neuen Gesetzgebung aber wir
brauchen auch diese Tests wir müssen
einschätzen können wie der momentane
Stand ist in Bezug auf den Schutz der
kritischen Infrastruktur und ich glaube
die Mitgliedstaaten werden das sehr
gerne auch begleiten dass wir jetzt
wirklich uns auch einsetzen für mehr
Schutz für mehr Prävention für mehr
Bereitschaft zu reparieren wenn es eine
Attacke gegeben hat mehr Schutz wie soll
denn der konkret aussehen das ist ja
klar da sind sich alle
Sicherheitsexperten eigentlich man kann
jetzt nicht jedes
Elektrizitätswerk jede Pipeline jeder
jede Stromtrasse quasi rund um die Uhr
bewachen was heißt denn ganz konkret
wenn sie von mehr Schutz sprechen meinen
sie das militärisch meinen sie das im
Sinne von Aufklärung durch
Nachrichtendienste
unterschiedliche Bestandteile gibt aber
was in den Vorschlägen steht ist zum
Beispiel dass wir nicht nur zwei
Bereiche haben also den Schutz der
kritischen Infrastruktur aber wir haben
jetzt eben 11 unterschiedliche Bereiche
aber letztendlich sind es natürlich die
Mitgliedstaaten die beurteilen müssen
was die kritische Infrastruktur ist und
wir müssen uns dann auch für die neue
Regulierung ansehen was es an
Möglichkeiten gibt was es an
Verpflichtungen gibt in Bezug auf
Sicherheitstest wo wir uns ansehen
müssen welche Pläne gibt es was kann man
an Schutz erreichen und was kann man
erreichen um Dinge wieder instand zu
setzen also unterschiedliche
Bestandteile natürlich auch in
Abhängigkeit der kritischen
Infrastruktur aber wichtig ist es dass
die Mitgliedstaaten diese Verantwortung
ja bereits national tragen aber was wir
momentan auf der europäischen Ebene tun
ist ganz entscheidend denn wir wissen
natürlich dass viele dieser
Infrastrukturbereiche nicht nur kritisch
für ein Land sind sondern für viele
Länder aus
brauchen wir die europäische
Gesetzgebung in diesem Bereich sagt über
Johannson die innenkommissarin der EU
vielen Dank
das Gespräch am Haus Termin Gründen vor
zwei Stunden aufgezeichnet während die
EU also neue Stresstests plant läuft ein
weiterer Stresstest längst von selbst in
den von Russland besetzten Gebieten in
der Ukraine eskaliert die Lage und
Hannah du hast den Überblick nach dem
Abschluss der scheinreferenten dort
haben die Pro russischen Verwalter den
Kreml nun um den Anschluss an Russland
gebeten laut Moskau könnte die Duma
voraussichtlich kommende Woche darüber
entscheiden Bundeskanzler Scholz
erklärte in einem Gespräch mit dem
ukrainischen Präsidenten selensky das
Deutschland die Ergebnisse der
scheinabstimmungen nicht anerkennen
werde
das Bundeskabinett hat eine
wohngeldreform auf den Weg gebracht
damit sollen vor allem
einkommensschwache Haushalte wegen der
hohen Energiekosten entlastet werden der
Entwurf sieht eine monatliche Anhebung
um 190 Euro auf 370 Euro vor außerdem
sollen deutlich mehr Menschen von den
Wohnkostenzuschuss profitieren so
könnten zu den bisher rund 600.000
Haushalten weitere 1,4 Millionen
hinzukommen die Reform soll nächstes
Jahr in Kraft treten Bundestag und
Bundesrat müssen noch zustimmen
und um Entlastungen ging es auch bei der
heutigen Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
die Chefinnen und Chefs der Länder
fordern von der Bundesregierung einen
schnellen energiepreisdeckel für Strom
Gas und Wärme das erklärte der
nordrhein-westfälische Ministerpräsident
wüst bei der anschließenden
Pressekonferenz zudem ging es um die
Finanzierung des dritten
entlastungspakets hier betonte wüst die
Forderung einer fairen Lastenverteilung
zwischen Bund und Ländern strittig blieb
laut berlins Regierender Bürgermeisterin
giff weiter gegen ein mögliches
Aussetzen der Schuldenbremse
der Aachener Bischof Helmut dieser ist
neuer missbrauchsbeauftragter der
Deutschen Bischofskonferenz wird sich
künftig um die Aufarbeitung von
sexualisierter Gewalt in der
katholischen Kirche kümmern dieser
erklärte sein Ziel sei eine Atmosphäre
zu schaffen in der Betroffene den Mut
fänden aus dem Dunkelfeld herauszutreten
die Bischofskonferenz will die
Aufarbeitung des miss Skandals zu dem
breiter aufstellen so soll es einen
neuen unabhängigen Expertenrat geben
angesichts des Todes einer jungen
Iranerin in Polizeigewahrsam und das
brutalen Vorgehens der iranischen
Regierung gegen demonstrierende gab es
auch heute wieder
Solidaritätskundgebungen in Deutschland
unter anderem in Berlin dabei sprach
sich der Ko-Vorsitzende der Grünen
nuripur für Sanktionen gegen Teheran aus
Morgen sind die Proteste in Iran Thema
in einer aktuellen Stunde des Bundestags
mehr dazu später an unserem heute
journal Update darin ein Interview mit
dem iranisch stämmigen
FDP-Generalsekretär diazaray der die
Proteste mit einer Revolution vergleicht
die Berliner Staatsanwaltschaft hat die
Räume der
afd-bundesgeschäftsstelle durchsucht
auch in anderen Bundesländern fanden
Durchsuchungen statt wie die Behörde
mitteilte dabei geht es nach Angaben der
Ermittler um den Anfangsverdacht des
Verstoßes gegen das Parteiengesetz sowie
der Untreue die Vorwürfe richten sich
gegen den früheren Parteichef Meuthen
und den ehemaligen Bundesschatzmeister
Vormann
freie und gleiche Wahlen sind die Basis
der Demokratie sie sicherzustellen
müsste selbstverständliche und
vornehmste Aufgabe des Staates sein die
Berliner Verwaltung hat da das lässt
sich jetzt schon sagen auf ganzer Linie
versagt bei den Wahlen zum
Landesparlament vor einem Jahr gab es
Zustände wie in einer Bananenrepublik da
konnte nicht gewählt werden obwohl
Menschen ihre Stimme abgeben wollten da
wurde noch gewählt obwohl die Wahllokale
längst hätten zu sein müssen und dann
das Chaos bei der Auszählung das alles
so heißt es heute ist nur die Spitze des
Eisbergs die Berlinwahl muss nach der
ersten Einschätzung des
Verfassungsgerichtshofs heute komplett
wiederholt werden Stefan Merseburger und
Carsten Behrendt
dass da was kommt war klar nur wie dick
es kommen würde nicht das Interesse
enorm daher ist das
Landesverfassungsgericht zur Verhandlung
in den großen Hörsaal der Freien
Universität gezogen und es kam richtig
dick die neuen Richter fordern so ihre
vorläufige Einschätzung eine komplette
Wiederholung der Berliner
Abgeordnetenhauswahl Bezirke inklusive
der Grund zu viel Chaos der
Verfassungsgerichtshof geht nach
vorläufiger Einschätzung davon aus dass
nur die Spitze des Eisberges hier
tatsächlich dokumentiert wurde an
wahlfehlern und das tatsächlich noch
viel mehr Wahlfehler sich ereignet haben
und zumutbare Warteschlangen
Stimmabgaben nach 18 Uhr fehlende und
vertauschte Stimmzettel abgewiesene
Wähler Fehler die Einfluss auf die
Zusammensetzung des landesparlamentes
hatten also mandatsrelevant waren so die
Verfassungsrichter die zuständige
sozialdemokratisch geführte senatsinnen
Anleitung sieht das anders wir haben
eigentlich festgestellt dass in neun von
zehn Wahllokalen eigentlich es keine
Vorkommnisse gab die andere
mandatsrelevanz haben das heißt das ist
eine hohe Quote nämlich von über 90
Prozent und hier habe ich den Eindruck
dass das der Verfassungsgerichtshof das
nicht berücksichtigt die Opposition
ficht das nicht an sie schaltet sofort
in den Wahlkampfmodus mit dem heutigen
Tag gefühlt eine regierende auf Abrufe
aber ich erwarte dass sie zumindest
funktionierende Neuwahlen noch
sicherstellen wird
Giffey und die Prominenz der Berliner
SPD scheuten heute die Kameras auch die
Grünen duckten sich ein schwerer Winter
steht bevor niemand in der
rot-grün-roten Koalition will Wahlkampf
von Neuwahlen die Schuldfrage aber wird
im Vorfeld schon mal geklärt
in erster Linie ist die Innenverwaltung
dafür zuständig das muss man auch mal
sagen und sie muss jetzt ihrer
Verantwortung gerecht werden
komplette Neuwahlen wurden heute
gefordert die Entscheidung aber fällt in
drei Monaten und was wenn es dann
richtig dick kommt
es wäre nur Neuland aber das wäre auch
vermittelbar denn eine solche
Schlamperei wie in Berlin vor einem Jahr
hat es in der Bundesrepublik noch nie
gegeben wie das Urteil auch ausfallen
mag sicher ist Berlin hat sich gehörig
blamiert
auch gegen das Ergebnis der
Bundestagswahl in Berlin gibt es
zahlreiche Einsprüche über sie soll in
Kürze der Bundestag entscheiden der
Bundeswahlleiter spricht von einem
systemischen Versagen in Berlin
da kann es nicht sehr wundern wenn das
Vertrauen ins Funktionieren unseres
Staates schwindet aber das ist nicht
alles zur miesen Stimmung in der Krise
kommen ganz grundsätzliche Zweifel auch
an der Demokratie selbst die gibt es in
ganz Deutschland wie die
Meinungsforscher sagen die heute den
sogenannten deutschlandmonitor
vorstellten Zitat in ganz Deutschland
geht es quasi abwärts die gibt es ganz
besonders im Osten des Landes Christiane
hübscher
Schwerin Zwickau Erfurt Leipzig
Magdeburg im Osten geht man montags
wieder auf die Straße gegen die hohen
Energiepreise gegen Russland Sanktionen
und vor allem gegen die Bundesregierung
alle haben Angst dass sie sag mal ein
zwei Monaten nichts mehr auf dem Konto
haben ihre Miete nicht mehr zahlen
können weil die Nebenkosten einen
auffressen erstmal wollen wir keinen
Krieg keine Waffenlieferung das möchten
wir nicht wir wollen nicht gefragt ich
verstehe die Politik in diesem Land
nicht mehr ich glaube die viele Menschen
verstehen das nicht ich habe meine
Wohnung kalt ich habe schon gesagt ich
bin vorhin reingekommen bei mir in der
Wohnung und habe gesagt verdammt ich
friere es ist der Sound zum neuen
Bericht des ostbeauftragten der
Bundesregierung Carsten Schneider wollte
einen neuen Blick auf den Osten er bekam
eine Generalabrechnung mit der Politik
viele Leute mit unzufrieden sind
sind Handlungsauftrag an die Politik und
Alarmsignal dass uns die Gesellschaft
dass sie zusammenbleibt und das merkt
man in den Zahlen dass Druck drin ist
und viele Leute auch echt auf dem
Zahnfleisch gehen die Studie schreckt
auf mit der politischen Situation
insgesamt zufrieden sind im Osten nur
noch 31 Prozent vor zwei Jahren waren es
noch 40 Prozent im Westen sind noch 44%
zufrieden aber der Rückgang ist hier
sogar noch stärker -10% in zwei Jahren
doch Demonstrationen gibt es bisher vor
allem im Osten in Thüringen hat sich die
Zahl der Protestler in nur drei Wochen
verdreifacht 18.000 waren es am Montag
der Innenminister fürchtet die
Unterwanderung durch rechtsextreme und
sagt das wird größer als jeder
corona-protest also das Potenzial ist
definitiv größer weil natürlich alle
betroffen sind von dem Preissteigerungen
aber es ist noch macht auch noch mal ein
Unterschied hier in Ostdeutschland es
ist leider so immer noch mehr als 30
Jahre nach der Wiedervereinigung die
Löhne sind hier niedriger die Vermögen
sind geringer als im Westen und das
heißt auch die Reserven sind geringer um
auch mal eine Krise aushalten zu können
das heißt ostdeutsches sind viel stärker
betroffen nur noch 39 Prozent der
Befragten ostdeutschen sind zufrieden
mit der Demokratie wie sie in
Deutschland funktioniert Ökonomen sehen
die Ursache dafür auch und immer noch in
der Umbruch Erfahrung der Wendezeit
diese erlebte Unsicherheit führt nicht
dazu dass man besser mit Unsicherheit
umgehen kann sondern im Gegenteil es
führt dazu dass man noch risikoaverser
wird dass man noch mehr schaut kann der
Staat mir nicht helfen die Stimmung ist
mies das gilt bundesweit aber noch
stärker im Osten die nächsten
Entlastungen müssten nun sitzen so der
ostbeauftragte Schneider heute
es gibt einen der dürfte diese Umfrage
Zahlen aus Deutschland heute mit großer
Zufriedenheit registriert haben der
sitzt 2000 Kilometer entfernt von hier
im Kreml
Hannah in der Sendung jetzt noch mal du
und da blicken wir Richtung
Großbritannien wo es gerade turbulent
zugeht auf den Finanzmärkten und die
Zentralbank deshalb heute in den
Notfallmodus geschaltet hat die Bank of
England hat angekündigt Staatsanleihen
zu kaufen und zwar ohne Obergrenze Frank
Bethmann warum hat sich die britische
Zentralbank jetzt zu diesem Schritt
entschieden weil die Not groß ist wie
groß sagt die Tatsache dass die Bank auf
England ursprünglich eigentlich anfangen
wollte die ihre hohen Bestände an
britischen Staatsanleihen zu verkaufen
heute nun die Rolle rückwärts als
Reaktion auf die radikalen
Steuersenkungspläne der neuen Regierung
die sich damit weiter enorm verschuldet
ohne Vorschläge für eine
Gegenfinanzierung zu machen das
britische Pfund Sterling stürzt
daraufhin ab zeitweise gegenüber dem
Dollar auf den tiefsten Stand seiner
Geschichte ein massiver Vertrauens
Entzug die britische Regierung allen
voran Finanzminister quarting kehrt
damit zur lockeren geldpol wieder zurück
experten schätzen dass die Steuerreform
die britischen Schulden um etwa 400
Milliarden Pfund erhöhen wird auch
deshalb schossen die Renditen für
britische Staatsanleihen nach oben also
jenem Darlehenszins mit dem sich der
britische Staat an den Finanzmärkten
Geld leihen kann nun wird klar was die
Bank auf England mit dem neuerlichen
aufkaufen von Staatsanleihen bezwickt
der darlehensins muss runter damit sich
London wieder billiger Verschulden kann
hoch her wird es morgen auch hier gehen
hinter mir laufen die letzten
Vorbereitungen für den Porsche
Börsengang den größten seit 25 Jahren
vielen Dank Frank für diese Einordnungen
der Hurrikan Ian ist an der Westküste
der US des US-Bundesstaats Florida auf
Land getroffen der Sturm wurde
inzwischen hochgestuft und erreicht nun
fast die schwerste Kategorie 5 die
Behörden warnen vor lebensbedrohlichen
Sturmfluten 2,5 Millionen Menschen waren
aufgerufen sich in Sicherheit zu bringen
zuvor hatte Hurricane Ian bereits in
Kuba schwere Schäden angerichtet und die
Stromversorgung lagen belegt zwei
Menschen kamen ums Leben mehr zu den
Besonderheiten der wirbelsturmsaison
diesem Jahr gleich im Wetter
zu den Lottozahlen an diesem Mittwoch
die lauten 4 12 13 33 44 49 Superzahl 6
so und jetzt kommt ein Bully Herbig Film
dessen Thema eigentlich wenig Anlass
bietet zu lachen gerade für uns
Journalisten nicht vor fast vier Jahren
kam der Skandal um den spiegelautor
Claas relotius heraus der sich ganze
Ereignisse und Protagonisten in seinen
Geschichten einfach ausgedacht hatte
etwas das jede und jeden mit Reporter
Herz fassungslos zurückließ morgen kommt
der Film dazu in die Kinos 1000 Zeilen
und er schafft wie Stefan Leifer zeigt
dass Kunststück nachdenklich zu sein und
gleichzeitig lustig
man sieht es nicht man hört es nicht man
spürt es nicht an dieser Szene ist
nichts real für einen Film kein Problem
für Journalismus ein großes ja und
deshalb will ich die heutige Sitzung
ganz gerne im Stehen verbringen wenn Sie
verstehen was ich meine real nur im
kranken Kopf eines jungen Mannes dem
alle glauben Journalisten zu sein
also ich freue mich auf den Artikel die
einen bewundern die anderen beneiden ihn
bei der Chronik während Hochstapler las
bogenius Erfolg hat hat sein Kollege Ron
Romero Zweifel die keiner hören will das
stimmt was ich mit dem Text von Lars ich
kann mir das nicht vorstellen das ist
nicht mein Problem dein Verhalten ist
unprofessionell und inakzeptabel nicht
dass ich das jetzt erstrebenswert finde
in einem Hochstapler irgendwie eine ein
Film zu widmen aber es ist natürlich für
für eine Geschichte eine tolle Vorlage
insofern habe ich mir den Vorfall da
genau angeguckt
und
hatte dann dazu auch letztendlich sofort
Bilder im Kopf Bilder die der Skandal um
class relotius liefert der Preis
gekrönte Reporter jahrelang druckte
Spiegel seine gefälschten Geschichten
Journalist Ron Moreno überführt relotius
als Betrüger sein Buch liefert die
Vorlage
das gibt ein paar Szenen in dem Film da
muss nicht schlucken also da muss ich
tatsächlich
an die Situationen denken die ich erlebt
habe sie sind nicht identisch aber für
mich war das ein sehr sehr
ungewöhnliches Gefühl
tausend Zeilen ist ein Film über Hybris
im Journalismus wir sind die Chronik die
Avantgarde des deutschen Journalismus
über Machtkämpfe in Medienhäusern denn
wenn er was dran wäre an romerosmeldern
jetzt ein Problem wieso ich weil die
robotage deiner Leitung unterstehen und
Schwachstellen im System alles was wir
hier schreiben wird auf Herz und Nieren
geprüft es ist ein in sich wie ich finde
sehr Ware Film weil er funktioniert als
Film weil die Protagonisten weil die
Figuren die darin vorkommen in sich
schlüssig sind
ich habe da mal ein paar Fragen
rasant erzählt Bully Herbig wie schwer
ist der Zweifel gegen den Erfolg hat ein
Lehrstück darüber wie meisterhaft
gelogen wie unverfroren betrogen und wie
ein Einzelfall den ganzen Journalismus
pervertieren kann eine so unterhaltsame
die sehenswerte David gegen Goliath
Geschichte
in unserem Film möchte man auch einfach
meiner Figur das Gute wünschen möchte
dass er gewinnt man möchte dass er das
Böse besiegt und ich glaube das ist
eigentlich immer ganz gute Prämisse 5
dieser Typ schreibt sich da irgendeinen
Scheiß zusammen der Film will Satire
sein entzieht sich aber den Genres er
ist kein Sitten Gemälde des Journalismus
sondern erzählt was passiert wenn an
seinen Grundfesten gerüttelt wird dass
das sogar lustig sein kann ist die
eigentliche Leistung des Bully Herbig
die Realität ist fast immer
komplizierter als eine gute Geschichte
unsere Welt ist selten schwarz-weiß sie
ist auch wenn das weniger sexy klingt
meistens voller Grautöne das im Kopf zu
haben hilft uns in den Medien und Ihnen
allen als Medien Nutzer so im
auslandsjournal gleich eine ausführliche
Reportage aus dem Iran über mutige
Frauen und Männer die trotz brutaler
Gewalt gegen das molaregime
Demonstrieren jeden Tag neu auch heute
wieder das war dieser Mittwoch im heute
journal danke dass Sie bei uns waren wir
wünschen Ihnen einen angenehmen Abend
[Musik]
guten Abend Hurrican Ian trifft jetzt
Florida nach dem heißen Sommer auf der
Nordhalbkugel sind die
Wassertemperaturen besonders hoch mehr
als 27 Grad gibt es in diesem
schraffierten Bereich sogar im südlichen
Mittelmeer ab 27 Grad Wassertemperatur
wenn ansonsten wenig los ist in der
Atmosphäre können sich tropische Stirn
entwickeln Wirbelstürme der höchsten
Kategorie 5 haben mittlere
Windgeschwindigkeiten von 252 Kilometer
pro Stunde und mehr da die Weltmeere
immer heißer werden entwickeln sich die
stärksten tropischen Wirbelstürme der
Kategorie 4 oder 5 häufiger sie werden
größer ziehen langsamer und ihre Zugbahn
wird länger
sie bringen Meter hohe Wellen mit und
hunderte Liter Regen wie jetzt aktuell
der Hurrikan ihren der zieht über
Florida hinweg und wird dann bis Freitag
die US-amerikanische Ostküste noch
einmal treffen dann allerdings in
deutlich abgeschwächter Form und damit
vom Hurrikan zurück zu unserem Wetter
hier in Deutschland Regen fällt heute
Nacht an den Küsten von Nord- und Ostsee
und auch am Alpenrand die Wolken hier in
der Mitte lockern auf da bildet sich
Nebel und da wird es kalt da sinken die
Werte auf drei bis 0 Grad am Boden kann
es frostig sein sonst liegen die
Tiefsttemperaturen nicht ganz so niedrig
morgen gibt es dann einige Regenschauer
im Nordwesten es fällt noch Regen im
Süden sonst zeigt sich häufiger die
Sonne und wechselhaft geht es in den
nächsten Tagen auch weiter guten Abend